now in your documentary age of delirium
there's so
many fascinating stories that you
covered in there from the train to the
to the buried printing press
um
and then when you combine all these
different stories with the apartment
bombings it's easy to see how you you
adopted this
clear vision of what was going on over
there and how these people are living in
their a completely different reality
right can you exp can you explain what
what was the story uh and where were you
at in your
career in moscow
at the point when you were on the train
and you got your briefcase stolen
oh well that was i had just arrived i
had just arrived the film describes that
that that incident
i was making
uh in those days
i mean this was this is the
1970s i was 29
and any you know i was experienced
by some standards but very inexperienced
you know if
you kept in mind just the the complexity
of the task that i that i had
carved out for myself which was to
understand the soviet union in any case
most of the correspondents in moscow did
not travel alone
uh they considered it was considered
dangerous
mostly their trips were arranged by the
soviet authorities that they had and
many of them didn't have the language
i was beginning to get the language but
it was still a little bit wobbly
and i took that
and i decided to visit the baltic
republics
and to meet there with
democratic dissidents
and national nationalists
in the baltic republics
and
that was unusual
for a western correspondent to travel
alone
uh and uh they uh
uh arranged
for me to have
as you know and they of course they
controlled you know
where i would be sitting who would be in
the compartment and they put uh two very
good-looking girls and a a uh another
guy in the compartment with me
and uh you know out of sharing
experience i thought i i assumed that uh
that was random i said well i i
suspected
that it wasn't random
but
but it was just so fantastic
and and i must say
say the women were so attractive and
they were well chosen and i'll tell you
that
that um
and this was this is a long time ago uh
and
uh
i just put aside my doubts maybe because
i wanted to who knows you know it was a
very tempting situation
but i was unmarried and and uh young guy
in
in a new a strange
country
and uh
the the the the one of the girls went he
got into
a bunk with one of the the with the male
guy with the the with who was
and the other with got into the upper
bunk with me
and
weren't you guys like taking shots of
cognac or something oh yeah they've
given us no where we had tea there was
some there was some kind of sedative in
the teeth that also you know relaxed
whatever resistance i had which was not
particularly great
but the uh now it's i think back on it
um
and this uh
i mean this happened
in 1977.
a good
uh
a good long time ago a good you know now
it's 45 years ago but but in any case
uh and then what you know while i was
occupied with this woman the the my
briefcase was stolen and my notes were
taken and the the
the uh
kgb got a hold of the addresses of the
people that i was supposed to see
and they and i was met at the train
station
uh
by the police
i gave a statement and then at at uh
when i went to my hotel
i was in count i was encountered by
while i was standing in line to register
at the hotel
someone came up to me and
offered to shake hands and then left a
piece of paper in my hand and there was
on the piece of paper
a telephone number and a message said
call this number from an automatic
telephone and i realized that this was
either
the dissidents
who were trying to get hold of me or the
kgb and i wasn't sure who it was who now
wanted to get ahold of me it was a
situation was just something absolutely
fantastic for an amer young american
in in the soviet union with no previous
experience of the police state
atmosphere there
you know to have i was without my
suitcase without uh including uh you
know things i
i needed and and notes i'd taken
uh
and so i i i
i made the call from a
audi you know from a
public telephone
and i told myself that if the the voice
that answered was estonian if they spoke
with an estonian accent i would assume
it was the dissidents
but if it was if they spoke in you know
a clear unaccented russian i would
assume it was the kgb well they the the
voices uh
were estonian
and i um
we ended up arranging a meeting and i
spent three days with people who
convinced me that they were the estonian
dissidents
and
uh
it was only when i got back to moscow
that i got a message
that the estonian dissidents had never
met with me
and i had spent all this time not with
the people i thought i was spending the
time with but with kgb agents
who were impersonating
dissidents you know this is an
experience but it taught you know it
taught me the fundamental lesson
which is uh in the soviet union seeing
is not necessarily believing
and uh
that story which by the way is is
included in my in my book and never
speak to strangers which
is a compil just recently released as a
compilation of my articles over 40 years
uh
you know i described this incident and
that tells you everything you need to
know about the nature of the soviet
union that you know that person stepping
out of the shadows he can be anyone wow
and
what was the story with the
it was fascinating seeing that printing
press that was buried under a flower bed
he had a there was this giant
trough of flowers and then like a big
water pail he had to like crank to move
to the side under like a giant two foot
slab of concrete and you guys climbed
underneath this concrete slab and he had
this massive printing press
how common was were things like that
well this was what they had to do in
this was in the baltic republics
uh the the example of
that print underground printing press
which was used i think to is to
print
a publication called the chronicle of
the lithuanian catholic church
which was
uh
a a a
unofficial publication which contained a
lot of information about nationalist
activities in lithuania
that
that was
perhaps more elaborate than
uh
other methods that were used i mean in
moscow itself where you had a lot of
people who sympathized with the
democratic movement
uh of the
chronicle of current events which was a
as
also an unofficial publication but on
the basis of the entire country
not just lithuania
was was produced because there were
hundreds of people who would type up
copies at home
with uh with many with many uh cop they
what they would do is they would get a
single copy and then they would put in
their typewriters five sheets and five
sheets of carbon paper
and uh and retype and that was going on
and that was the sami's
sami's dot is the russian term for self
some itself is dot is published sami's
dot means self-publishing and the sami's
dot machine in moscow and saint
petersburg which are the big cities
uh was uh involved
you know a lot of people certainly
certainly scores probably hundreds
who would get
uh copies of
this forbidden literature forbidden
unofficial literature and they would you
know retype it
so each person could produce five copies
and then those five copies would be
given to five people who would produce
an additional
five copies uh and and it you know would
it would multiply
so
uh but the but the
printing press in
in uh lithuania
that was featured in the film that was
you know the things like that also
happened
there were also cases where people uh
simply
you know dug out
of
bunkers
which
yeah which were hidden from the
authorities
and uh piece by piece constructed uh
uh
you know underground presses and
and produced material which was then
circulated
you